foreign
[Music]
this is just another one of the half
dozen builds or so that often use in my
story videos where I quite often have
people asking what I'm using so this
will be somewhere quick I can point
people towards
one of the things I love about the
division is that there is a ridiculous
number of options for you to vary up
your builds to completely change the way
you play through content for me I love
playing the sniper from time to time
there's something about the one tap
headshot kill that is incredibly
satisfying
I don't watch build videos and I'll
never claim that whatever I've built is
the best of its type as I'm a strong
believer in the fact that there is no
person on the internet that can throw
some pieces together run the numbers and
decide what is the best most amazing
god-like OP build for your style of play
instead use what you see as a template
and adjust to whatever works best for
you
it's also worth noting that I play solo
the majority of the time so a lot of my
builds are certainly not specked for
group play
I've been playing around and changing
things on this build for the last 12
months and I can absolutely guarantee
that there are many more ways to gain
considerably higher damage numbers but
maybe it's just me but I really don't
like having to proc a dozen different
talents across multiple weapons and
skills in order to get the chance to
land a high damage shot I I just want to
shoot stuff in the head and kill them
with a little hassle but some people
like this so I'll suggest some
alternative pieces along the way
I'm not going to read through the set
perks or each individual Talent
description in order to inflate the
length of this video because by now I'm
sure you know what these are or you can
read for yourself in game
the idea behind this build is
ridiculously straightforward stack all
the headshot damage you can
here I am running four pieces of Aces
and Eights on the mask gloves holster
and knee pads the backpack is the uraldi
Holdings with the Vigilant Talent rolled
onto it eraldi because of the Native
brand seat bonus of 10 maximum rifle
damage the chest is the named Walker
Harris and Co brand set piece called
chain killer which is the perfect
Headhunter Talent
but slightly more damage you could swap
out the knee pads for Sawyers but
personally I move around far too much to
take advantage of this Talent
all pieces have been rolled into weapon
damage for the core attribute and
headshot damage as the secondary
attribute you should be able to get
around 300 or more headshot damage I
spend a lot of time playing around
trying to find a balance between
critical hit chance critical hit damage
and headshot damage to see if I can get
the best of both but I found putting
everything into headshot as being the
most consistent
the primary weapon I use is the white
death for its huge boost to headshot
damage the talent is a lucky shot
because you know I don't have perfect
day you could certainly Swap this out
for something that will increase your
damage further just remember though the
more time you spend reloading the less
damage you'll be doing over time
you may have noticed that I don't run a
maximum scope yes this means I lose out
on up to 45 extra headshot damage but
there is a reason for this
I've enjoyed playing the sniper roll
since the days of the division 1 where I
mainly played on Xbox firstly sniping on
Console at least in the division 1 is
much easier than on PC the auto aim on
controller when popping the left trigger
right trigger over and over was
extremely op hence why I used the lucky
shot Talent on PC
but also the main difference between the
division 1 and 2 is the forced scoping
in division two
it may not be much to most but I find
the scoping far too slow for my
playstyle and also a bit limiting for
the varied range you need to be able to
shoot as a solo player
the secondary weapon is the classic M1A
this is justify I'm struggling to hit my
headshots and I need something a little
faster if I'm being rushed down you may
instead choose to use something a little
more flexible like an AR or SMG
the specialization is Sharpshooter
because this is the one that gives the
most benefits to a sniper build like
heat shot damage and increased armor
while in cover
I also quite like the tactician drone
just to help keep me aware of enemies
sneaking up around me
the other skill I use is the classic
reviver Hive because you know solo
player and practically no armor
and that about wraps it up pretty much
full glass Cannon so you need to utilize
cover to cover movement
as a solo player you often have to play
the sniper in a much more flexible way
and be prepared for engagements at all
ranges I wouldn't say that this was a
particularly easy playstyle but it's
certainly quite satisfying once you get
the hang of it like I said earlier there
are many ways to hit much higher numbers
but in most cases on heroic you
shouldn't need any more for one-hit
kills just land those headshots
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]